hi
this is a video about opening up a steam
deck to replace one or more of the
components inside it specifically we're
going to cover the thumbsticks and the
ssd
in one way this is a how-to video but in
another way it's a why you really
shouldn't do this video
that's because even though it's your pc
or will be once you've received your
steam deck
and you have every right to open it up
and do what you want we at valve really
don't recommend that you ever open it up
the steam deck is a very tightly
designed system and the parts are chosen
carefully for this product with its
specific construction
so they aren't really designed to be
user swappable
opening up and replacing parts might
mess things up like profoundly for
example if you damage the battery the
whole thing could catch fire later which
would be bad
so be forewarned and leave this kind of
thing to professionals unless you really
feel like taking big risks with your
property and with your life which could
end if you do this wrong just saying
also the warranty doesn't cover any
damage that you do
however having said all that we also
wanted to make this video to simply show
you what's inside the steam deck
taking things apart and putting them
back together is cool especially
powerful handheld gaming computers
please note
the screws that secure the housing are
what's called self-tapping screws and
they're embedded in plastic bosses they
can be removed and reinstalled but it's
much easier to strip or over torque
screws of this type compared to standard
ones so be aware that they're very
sensitive and either the screws or the
housing can be damaged
a torque wrench does help prevent damage
opening the case immediately weakens it
and makes the product less drop
resistant there's no way to avoid this
so just know that the structural
integrity of your deck will be lessened
somewhat by doing any of this
static electricity can easily break your
steam deck permanently
basically if a spark jumps from you to
one of the integrated circuits on the
board it'll probably fry some of the
parts forever if you're unfamiliar with
preventing electrostatic discharge you
should probably stop doing this and turn
it over to a pro
first remove these four screws
then these four
note that they're different sizes so
start keeping your screws organized to
help you when it comes time to
reassemble everything after the screws
are out you just need to pry the case
open
try not to break a fingernail that hurts
note that this video shows
pre-production hardware and there will
be some differences between what you see
here and the steam deck that you own
this is the battery before proceeding
it's important to disconnect it do that
by unplugging these wires here
the first component we're going to
replace is the thumb stick
this part is easy to remove be aware
that the whole assembly is custom the
stick the board and the cap
replacing these will require matching
the custom parts exactly stay tuned in
the coming months for a source for
replacement parts thumbsticks ssds and
possibly more
lift this latch
unplug the flex cable here
remove these three screws
and then take the stick assembly out
that's it
now just reverse all that to put another
one back in let's move on to the ssd
we don't recommend replacing the
included drive what we do recommend for
increasing your storage capacity is the
handy microsd card slot so much easier
and plenty fast
please note before attempting an ssd
replacement an off-the-shelf ssd could
cause problems
one power consumption an off-the-shelf
ssd can draw more power than the
original drive which could cause
overheating and reduce battery life
two electromagnetic interference
our ssd is located very close to our
wireless module and was specifically
chosen and tested to not interfere with
wi-fi and bluetooth an off-the-shelf ssd
might have a different emissions pattern
and could compromise wireless
performance
three mechanical we place components on
the motherboard underneath the ssd and a
different one might mechanically
interfere with these components
especially during vibration
four assembly
at least one screw which holds down the
thermal module onto the apu is also used
to hold down the shield can
removing this screw can impact the
thermal performance of the thermal
module
here we go
first we're working on removing this
outer shield as you've just seen these
two screws come first two more screws
under here
okay now you can actually remove the
shield but be super careful to not
disturb the whole thermal setup
very important to make doubly sure that
the battery is disconnected before
proceeding
now disconnect the drive
note that all steam deck models use the
m.2 connector for internal storage
including the 64 gigabyte model
to actually remove the ssd
remove one more screw here
that's it
[Music]
we haven't filmed the entire reassembly
process but as we mentioned with the
thumb stick it's basically doing this
whole thing again but backwards remember
if you have followed these directions
correctly you've done absolutely none of
the preceding steps
but you're more informed now about
what's inside your steam deck
anyway thanks for watching and as always
let us know what you think